we just came back from an amazing dive
we were diving on a pinnacle there were
so many Jack surrounded and the
Hammerhead the hammerheads came over he
was really really beautiful and then
when we were in the boat we saw all this
movement on the surface and that was a
bait ball a school of snappers and other
fish and macro and tuna in charge it was
really really amazing and then we went
to another side and we saw the most
beautiful fish an orange face like this
that looks like a sponge it's a frogfish
it doesn't have a traditional fins it
doesn't swim it has kind of feed and
transform fins that are like feet and it
was on the bottom really remarkable side
this place this place cockers is really
really amazing it's so glad that this
place is protected